welcome everyone this is the first
screencast in our series on analysis
methods in nlp this is one of my
favorite units in the course because
it's directly oriented toward helping
you do even better final projects
now there's a lot we could discuss under
the rubric of analysis methods in nlp
i've chosen four things
the first two fall under the heading of
behavioral evaluations we'll talk about
adversarial testing which is a very
flexible way for you to expose that your
system might have some weaknesses or
fail to capture some linguistic
phenomenon in a very systematic way
and then at this point we also have the
opportunity for a number of tasks to do
adversarial training and testing these
would be large data sets that are full
of examples that we know are difficult
for present day architecture so for
whatever architecture you're exploring
this would be a chance to really stress
test that architecture
and then we're going to move beyond
behavioral evaluations to talk about
what i've called structural evaluation
methods and these include probing and
feature attribution
these are techniques that you could use
to peer inside your system and gain an
understanding of what its hidden
representations are like and how those
representations are impacting the
model's predictions
the motivations for this are many here
are just a few high-level ones that are
kind of oriented toward projects the
first is just that we might want to find
the limits of the system that you're
developing all our systems have
limitations and finding them is always
scientifically useful
we might just also want to understand
your system's behavior better what are
its internal representations like and
how are they feeding into its final
predictions and its overall behaviors
that's also just incredibly rewarding
and both of these things might feed into
just achieving more robust systems to
the extent that we can find weaknesses
and understand
behaviors we can possibly take steps
toward building even more robust systems
and as i said all of this is oriented
toward your final projects the
techniques that we're discussing are
powerful and easy ways to improve the
analysis section of a paper analysis
sections are important but it can be
difficult to write them it feels very
open-ended and often very unstructured
people talk in general ways about doing
error analysis and so forth but it can
be hard to pinpoint exactly what would
be productive i think the methods that
we're talking about here are very
generally applicable
and can lead to really productive and
rich analysis sections
let's begin with adversarial testing
this is a mode that we've talked about
before the examples on this slide are
from this now classic paper glochner at
all 2018 called breaking nli and what
they did is only really mildly
adversarial it's just kind of a
challenge and it exposes some lack of
systematicity in certain nli models so
here's what they did they began from
snli examples like a little girl is
kneeling in the dirt crying entails a
little girl is very sad and they simply
use lexical resources to change the
hypothesis by one word so that it now
reads a little girl is very unhappy
we would expect a system that truly
understood the reasoning involved in
these examples to continue to predict
entail in the second case because these
examples are roughly synonymous but what
they found is that systems would often
start to predict contradiction possibly
because of the negation that occurs here
the second example is similar we begin
from the sli example an elderly couple
are sitting outside a restaurant
enjoying wine entails a couple drinking
wine and here they just changed wine to
champagne what we would expect is that a
system that knew about these lexical
items and their relations would flip to
predicting neutral in this case
but as you might imagine systems
continue to predict entails because they
have only a very fuzzy understanding of
how wine and champagne are related to
each other
here's the results table and recall this
is a 2018 paper and what they're mainly
testing here are models that we might
regard as precursors to the transformers
that we've been so focused on and the
picture is very clear these models do
well on the snli test set mid to high
80s but their performance plummets on
this new adversarial test set
there are two exceptions down here this
wordnet baseline and the kim
architecture but it's important to note
that these models effectively had access
directly in the case of wordnet and
indirectly in the case of kim to the
lexical resource that was used to create
the adversarial test
and so they don't see such a large
performance drop here but even still all
of these numbers are kind of modest at
this point
and i told you that this was an
interesting story here's the interesting
twist at this point in 2021 you can
simply download roberta mnli that's the
roberta parameters fine-tuned on the
multi-nli data set
and run this adversarial test and what
you find is that that model does
astoundingly well on the breaking nli
data set i would focus on these two f1
scores here for the two classes where we
have a lot of support contradiction and
entailment the numbers are above 90 as
is the accuracy here which is directly
comparable to the numbers that glockner
had all reported an amazing
accomplishment recall that the original
examples from the um adversarial test
are from snli this is multi-nli it was
not developed specifically to solve this
adversarial test and nonetheless it
looks like roberta has systematic
knowledge of the lexical relations
involved and required to solve this
adversarial test so possibly a markov
real progress
as i said you can also for selected
tasks move into the mode of doing
adversarial training and testing um here
are the cases i know where the data set
is large enough to support training and
testing on examples that were created
via some adversarial dynamic common
sense reasoning natural language
inference question answering sentiment
and hate speech and as i said this is a
really exciting opportunity to see just
how robust your system is when exposed
to examples that we know are difficult
for modern architectures because that's
how these data sets were designed
now let's move into the more behavioral
mode we'll start with probing of
internal representations probes are
little supervised models typically that
you fit on the internal representations
of your model of interest to sort of
expose what those hidden representations
latently encode this is from a classic
paper by ian tenney at all 2019
and what we have along the x-axis is the
burt layer starting from the embedding
layer and going to 24 this is burnt
large so there are 24 layers and the
picture is quite striking as you start
from the top here and move down you can
see that as we move from more syntactic
things up into more discourse-y semantic
content like co-ref and
relation extraction you find that the
higher layers of the burp model are
encoding that information latently
that's what these probing results reveal
in this picture quite striking look at
what the pre-training process in this
case of bert is learning latently about
the structures of language
and then we'll finally talk about
feature attribution which is one step
further in this more introspective mode
because here as you'll see i think we
can get a really deep picture at how
individual features and representations
are directly related to the model's
predictions what i've done here is use
the integrated gradients model which is
the model that we'll focus on i ran it
on a sentiment model and you can see
here we have the true label the
predicted label with the probability and
then we have word level importances as
measured by integrated gradients where
blue means it's a bias toward positive
predictions and red means it's a bias
toward negative predictions
uh and i've picked an example that i
think kind of stress tests the model
it's a little bit adversarial because
it's all these examples involve mean
in the sense of good as in a mean apple
pie meaning a delicious or good one
and you can see that by and large this
model's predictions are pretty
systematic it's mostly predicting
positive for variants like they sell
they make he makes although this last
one he sells might worry us a little bit
because it has flipped to negative
despite the changes to the example being
truly incidental
and this might point to a way in which
the model does or doesn't have knowledge
of how the individual components of
these examples should be predict should
be feeding into the final predictions
that the model makes i think that's a
wonderful opportunity to get a sense for
how robust the model is actually going
to be to variations like the one that
you see here
you